we tend to think we know what the good
life is so we tend to think basically to
lead a good life you should look within
I'm try to find yourself find your true
self and then spend your life being as
sincere and authentic to that true self
as you can and if you do that the idea
is you'll live life on your own terms
and sure you can't control what will
happen to you but at least you've lived
your life as you were meant to live it
and you'll be true to yourself now
that sounds great except suppose that
all of it is wrong
suppose as our philosophers here would
say we're very very messy selves and
we're messy cells that fall into these
patterns of responses in the world and
therefore what you're finding when you
look within or just these sets of
patterned responses that you've fallen
into now if that's the problem that that
we face as humans then the notion of
flourishing is very different the way to
live a flourishing good life is by
breaking these patterns and creating
worlds within which you and those around
you can flourish that's a good life and
you're not going to do it by looking
within and finding yourself because
again you're probably just gonna hit a
bunch of patterns you've fallen into and
you're focusing also on yourself
whereas if we are patterned creatures
much of what we are depends on these
patterns we're falling into what those
around us so the good life for these
philosophers would mean you're trying to
create worlds within which you and those
around you can flourish at a mundane
level so immediate friendships family at
a larger societal level - and that's
constant work the idea is it's constant
work working through these patterns
we're falling into altering these
patterns of breaking these patterns
creating different patterns and it's an
endless work of every situation from the
very mundane to the very very large
scale of constantly trying to
shift these patterns for the better and
division is that and really only that is
what the good life is the good life is a
world in which as many of us as possible
ideally everyone is flourishing and
you'll never get there but it's a
lifelong process of ever trying to
create worlds within which we can search
one of the ideas these philosophers will
talk a lot about is to Train spontaneity
this may seem like the total oxymoron I
mean we tend to think spontaneity means
simply breaking from convention and
doing whatever you want it to but they
would say even if you do that that will
always be momentary and then you have to
return to the conventions and the
conventions are unchanged so what they
will rather say is think of spontaneity
something like learning a musical
instrument or learning a sport something
that takes incredible amounts of
training but the goal at the end of the
training let's say playing a piano the
goal at the end of that is to reach a
point where you can play as they would
say spontaneously sensing the music
sensing the mood of the room sensing how
to shift how you're playing a piano to
shift that the atmosphere around you
something you can only achieve by years
and years of training now we know that
sort of thing works for a piano playing
or or sports but what if we actually
thought of our lives or our
organizations we're working in in the
exact same way so what you're trying to
do is train yourself as an individual or
in an organization to create an
atmosphere in which you're training
people to spontaneously be able to
connect in ways that he otherwise
couldn't and that's putting it very
abstractly so now let me get extremely
concrete so what would this mean let's
imagine you have an atmosphere in the
workplace where you feel the problem is
and again the keys are always trying to
see what are the dangerous patterns that
are setting in so one common one is
people aren't talking enough to each
other they're not connecting enough they
connect if they're in a meeting but then
even if the meetings are well-run it's
only one
for a brief moment so how do you get
people to connect more well you start
doing little things to create those
connections a common one that's been
done in the past few years is to tear
down walls so you tear down walls with
glass in where there used to be a wall
so even if there is a wall you can only
see through that physically gets people
connecting more but even there of course
dangerous patterns can set in I mean if
people feel that they actually are two
connected sort of don't have places
where they can work together without
others constantly around them that can
create problems too and so what you're
constantly trying to do is to look at
what sorts of patterns are developing
assume that most patterns are going to
have potentially dangerous consequences
of side effects usually unintended and
so you're constantly trying to create
the conditions within which people are
really able to flourish and it's
constant work so you'll do something
you'll tear down those walls that'll
work perfectly but then again dangerous
patterns begin to set in so you'll say
okay let's have a few meeting spaces
that aren't open then that may work
wonderfully but that'll create some
other problems and so you're thinking of
yourself is kind of the equivalent of
and it's pushing the metaphor but you're
sort of the piano player except what the
world you're creating isn't simply
simply the atmosphere through your music
you're actually creating a much larger
atmosphere in the entire world around
you by the ways you're you're talking to
people the ways you're connecting with
people where you have walls where you
don't have walls and all of these things
have an incredible impact on the entire
atmosphere of an organization these are
the little things we tend not to focus a
lot on our philosophers would say it's
those little things that have huge
repercussions in terms of the entire
feeling of it an area entire ways that
people can connect and the kinds of
ideas that can come out of that work
force